what's going on guys this is rob and uh
like like two years ago right a year and
a half two years ago i did a live stream
on the comments explained twitch channel
which i'll link to the video in
particular that i'm referencing but i
basically laid out how it is we could
introduce wolverine into the marvel
cinematic universe and to a larger
degree how we could introduce mutants
now a lot of the more recent revelations
from like one division the fact that
wanda's basically had powers ever since
she was a little girl the prevailing
theory that's been very very popular
right now which is that wanda is
actually a mutant it's something that
nobody seems to know it not even she
really knows it a lot of that seems to
at least to a degree flew in the face of
what i had come up with but a lot of
what i've theorized would still actually
work in terms of the origins of mutants
maybe maybe not right in terms of like
how to bring wolverine into the mcu
absolutely but it could very much tie
into the origin of mutants as well and
we'll talk about that once we get
towards the end of this video
specifically uh when it came to baron
bond strucker wanda pietro that kind of
stuff so here's what i want to do the
first thing i want to establish and i'm
not going to run over each individual
item but i want to establish that i'm
going to be pulling elements from
different aspects of marvel comics from
the ultimate universe from the main
marvel universe different things like
that and sort of condense it all down
but i'll make it super easy so here's
the idea behind this let's go back to
captain america the first avenger and
let's also invoke captain america the
winter soldier what do we know about
captain america the first avengers right
the steve rogers was a kid that really
really wanted to fight against the axis
forces during world war ii but he was
too small too skinny he ended up
becoming the first successful candidate
for the super soldier serum that was
created by abraham erskine who didn't
lose his mind and become a villain and
then he became captain america he fought
in world war ii for a little while he
almost banged peggy carter and then he
was basically frozen in a block of ice
for 70 years roll credits now let's move
on to captain america the winter soldier
now what do we know referencing captain
america and the winter soldier we know
that after the perceived death of steve
rogers the mission had to go on and that
what happened is that peggy carter and
howard stark and chester phillips formed
the strategic science reserve or
strategic scientific reserve i can't
remember which one is which but
regardless they formed the organization
that would eventually go on to become
shield the other thing we know is that
from arnhem zola hydra started regrowing
in the ssr and eventually shield all the
way to the point that by the 1960s 1970s
hydra had been completely in control of
shield remember one of the things that
artem zola said is that for decades
they've been sowing conflict reaping war
so it's not as though hydra hadn't fully
assumed control of shield until we got
to the events of captain america the
winter soldier and like robert redford's
character all that kind of stuff no no
no they've been doing it for a long long
time it's just no one had known about it
so let's let's say that since the 1960s
hydra had basically been manipulating
things had been like in full control of
shield now this is important
because let's say that with hydra being
in control of shield one of the things
that hydra wanted to do was create more
captain americas but with abraham
erskine being dead and and steve rogers
being frozen in a block of ice but being
assumed dead there was no conceivable
means to duplicate that but what they
ended up doing by whatever manner and
whatever means is they said we're going
to try to create more captain america
we're going to try to create things that
are better than captain america and they
will be agents of hydra so they can
infiltrate society where they can help
us basically conquer the world whatever
the case happens to be and so what they
did is they formed something called
weapons plus and weapons plus was
basically the umbrella project under
that you had weapon 1 and 2 and 3 and 4
running all the way up to weapon 10
which we'll talk about here in a minute
now let's say that with hydra operating
and basically controlling shield in the
1960s 1970s and 80s and 90s that in the
60s per se this was the age of the cold
war right this was the age of like the
spy game technically the cold war been
going on since like the end of world war
ii so we'll say from like the the early
1950s basically going until about the
80s but regardless the cold war was the
age of spies and so let's say that with
hydra controlling shield while they did
have all kinds of agents what they also
had were just black ops wet work teams
these were teams that as far as their
mission was concerned was to go and
infiltrate some dictator somewhere who
had gotten his hands on on some kind of
a nuclear device or some crazy fanatic
somewhere who got his hands on like a
dirty bomb whatever it was that was the
mission that they were officially told
right that was their story what was
really happening here is they were being
sent in to various places to take out
people who were credible threats to
hydra all this time hydra has weapons
plus and hydra's got weapon one and they
got weapon two weapon three and they're
doing stuff like bonding cybernetic
implants to animals right or bonding
them to people or experimenting with
drugs and in terms of like you know was
it frank simpson nuke right he takes the
red white and blue pill so like amp him
up to keep him stable or bring him down
different things along those lines right
like nuke you guys may remember or frank
simpson you may remember from like the
the jessica jones tv show the blonde guy
who kept popping all those pills and if
he didn't he'd lose his mind like that
guy right he's actually a weapons
weapons plus project and marvel comics
now the important thing here is that
among all these different teams there's
one guy who stands out in particular
who's ridiculously capable right as far
as where where he has no powers and in
fact we can say he has no powers that at
this point in time wolverine in his life
has no healing factor he's got no claws
he's just that damn good at being a spot
right it's like he's got a natural
aptitude for espionage for for stealth
and guile for just killing people right
it's almost like an ingrained part of
him and hydra notices this and hydra's
like okay we need this guy we're gonna
bring this guy in like this guy's gonna
be the next test subject for our weapons
plus project whatever it happens to be
right whatever form it takes it just
happens to be this guy is the 10th test
subject also known
as weapon x and so what this does is it
basically brings wolverine into that
actual name now here's the kicker to
this that as hydra is experimenting on
him and studying his genes and all kind
of stuff they realize there's a gene in
his body that is dormant and they have
no idea what it represents it doesn't
match any known database on the planet
there's nothing in the in the discovery
of the human genome that says anything
about this particular gene
it's all it's almost like it's not even
of this earth now kind of a sidetrack
here we can say that it was put there by
the celestials or whatever it is but in
effect this is his mutant gene hydra not
knowing what it is activates it and
that's when wolverine gets bone claws
and that's when wolverine gets his
healing factor and so it's like okay so
cool we kind of have like the the
framework of wolverine the big question
we have to ask here is how do we go from
wolverine being a guy with bone claws
and a healing factor to wolverine having
adamantium bonded to a skeleton
enter myron maclaine okay who's myron
maclean in marvel comics meyer mclean
was a metallurgist so let's walk away
from this theory for a second and let's
focus on the comics for a second so in
marvel comics during world war ii
captain america and the invaders so the
original human torch jim hammond name
with the submariner bucky barnes they
fought alongside the wakandans helping
to fend off german forces and that as a
result of this there were two things
that came out of it the first is that
captain america realized the wakandans
used circular shields unlike his shield
which at the time was in the shape of an
iron the benefit of using a circular
shield is that yes it could be used for
defense to block attacks things like
that but they could also throw it it
could be an offensive weapon the other
thing that came out of this is that as
thanks for his efforts in helping them
defeat the germans captain america was
given a small shard of vibranium by the
wakandans and so when he came back to
the united states he told the federal
government make me a new shield make it
round and put this vibranium in it and
so the government contracted out to
myron mclean who was a metallurgist
myron mclean took that vibranium
basically started building a new shield
and much like the discovery of
penicillin fell asleep during the
process when he woke up captain america
shield was created but it was not just a
vibranium shield it was a vibranium iron
alloy shield the issue with this is that
meyer mcclain didn't readily know that
so what he did is he tried to duplicate
captain america's shield and
accidentally created adamantium in the
process now back into our theory how do
we introduce adamantium into the marvel
cinematic universe we use wakanda and
here's the reason why if you guys
remember from iron man 2 that's scene at
the end of the movie when tony stark is
talking to nick fury and there's the map
behind him and basically it shows all
the different points where there are
people with essentially powers right
beings of interest right places of
interest to uh to to shield itself that
you had the atlantic ocean which of
course was a direct reference to
atlantis i.e neymar the submariner there
was also one in africa basically shield
knew about wakanda now we can't invoke
ulysses claw because ulysses claw did
not successfully invade wakanda and
steal vibranium until 1992. we're still
talking about the 1960s maybe the 1970s
so 20 years before that ever happened
here's the kicker we don't know how long
shield had known about wakanda we don't
know if shield only discovered wakanda
because technology in the 2000s going
forward had become sufficiently advanced
enough to where they could even detect
it or if they had known about wakanda
for a long time but were just never able
to get in maybe they were who knows who
cares the important thing here is
whether they knew about wakanda and were
trying to find a way to duplicate
vibranium or if meyer mclean was simply
just a hydra meddler just right a hydra
agent who was just trying to find some
way to create a super advanced metal the
end result is we land on adamantium and
so circling back once hydra activates
the secret gene of wolverine and then
basically realize he has a healing
factor and he's got bone claws they bond
adamantium to a skeleton they try to
basically turn him into an agent and he
ends up escaping and the rest is history
right he just kind of goes forward and
does his own thing now having said all
that here's the biggest takeaway from
all this right because that's just
wolverine right here's the biggest take
away from all of this if we really want
to tie this into like wanda and pietro
and all that kind of stuff what we do is
we say that this whole thing right
because up until that point uh baron von
strucker and then like one of the things
he said is that there are multiple hydra
agencies around the world who are
basically conducting the exact same
experiment that he's doing maybe not
using the mind stone because as far as
we're aware there's only one of those
but sokovia is seemingly not the only
place where hydra detected genetic
abnormalities what this does in terms of
them like discovering wolverine
activating wolverine's gene discovering
that he has powers is it lends a basis
and an explanation to why it is that
baron von strucker and the rest of hydra
are going to places where they discover
people with genetic abnormalities and
then taking them and activating those
genes that the mind stone is what baron
von strucker use because perhaps it's
the most effective right maybe it's the
easiest thing we don't really know the
plot demanded it like it really matters
but this explains why it is that he knew
to activate the genes of pietro and he
knew to activate or at least believed he
was activating the gene of wanda that in
turn of course pushed her powers and
that kind of thing but basically it
gives us the origin of wolverine and it
gives us an explanation of other people
around the world all having these
genetic abnormalities but in effect
they're all basically mutants with x
genes that simply haven't been activated
yet it also neatly ties in to wanda
gaining her powers in the sense that her
powers activated almost in the exact
same way they do occasionally in marvel
comics which is through like moments of
duress we talked about that in our
previous video moments of high duress
led to her powers being activated right
so let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section right i mean do
you think this works like do you think
this theory works because when i was
streaming it a couple years ago people
loved it they were like dude this is
amazing like dude this theory is perfect
you should be working for marvel man
like if marvel doesn't use this idea
it's a terrible thing let me know what
you guys think of course i can also
count on you guys to just punch holes to
just swiss cheese this theory i could
totally count on you guys to do that max
i imagine some of you guys are already
typing away right and that's why i love
you guys because you guys just you guys
make my theories better but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section and i will catch you all later
peace
wait a minute peace there we go